[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF KEMBER: Hello, hi.
My name is Jeff Kember.
I'm a-- office of the CTO,
Technical Director for Google,
and I've had the opportunity
to work at such companies
as Pixar, and Framestore, ILM.
I've been with Google
about 2 and 1/2 years,
and really excited to be here
to talk with you guys today
about cloud rendering.
We also have Hannes Ricklefs
here today with us from MPC,
and he'll be talking
about some exciting work
that they did on our cloud
in the fall of last year.
So the concept of
batch rendering--
batch computing,
batch rendering,
it's all kind of synonymous.
When we talk about
batch compute,
rendering is one of the
many use cases of it.
So if anyone is here
from other industries,
be it finance or oil and gas
or other high performance
computing, the same
architectures and technologies,
network transfer storage,
techniques, and such
we're going to be
talking about today, can
be utilized across the realm.
When we look an
architecture diagram later,
I'll point out some
of the intricacies
to the different
markets as well.
So Google has a unique
global network, and that's
something I'm really
excited about,
in the fact that you
can onboard in Helsinki
and jump off in Taiwan,
or get on in Tokyo
and jump off in Frankfurt,
you're on our private network,
under the ocean,
100% of the time.
As soon as your appeared
with us ina POP,
you're encrypted in
motion and at rest.
So the ability to offer
that level of service
is because of this backbone.
The content delivery
network we have as well
is peered in more than
100 different locations.
You can see we have additional
trans Atlantic and Pacific
links being lit up in 2018.
So this road map is obviously
subject change for timing,
but this is where we are today.
So when we talk about
cloud scale rendering,
it's exciting to me.
I get to meet with customers who
have a whole bunch of compute
on prem, and they say we want
5,000 cores or 20,000 cores.
And after we finished the
architectural diagrams
and conversations and look
at the workloads and such,
it's quite common to come
out with a quota that's
100,000 cores.
And it's not that they are
going to run that sustained,
but they're in a situation
where they can use preemptibles,
which we'll talk about
later, but they can use them
for shorter periods of time,
and they can be in a scenario
where they can say, instead
of running for 24 hours
as they would normally, they
can run for maybe four or five
hours at really
high compute numbers
in order to get the
frames back quickly.
This is a list of
some of the things
we're going to
talk about in terms
of being able to put together
a successful cloud rendering
strategy on Google.
So the first thing
you need to do
is to be able to
connect with us.
And with the 100 plus points
of presence, most major cities
in the planet we
have a fiber line
into the exchange there,
or multiple exchanges
in each of those cities.
The opportunity
to connect with us
in a variety of different ways,
and we have a new announcement
at the show that occurred in
the keynote earlier this week.
We can talk about our
connection options.
So we have a direct
peering option,
we have carrier
interconnect, and then
of course we have a
managed VPN offering.
And the opportunity to
connect with us directly
over the internet to
initial proof of concepts
and to be able to
put smaller files up
on the cloud and such,
that's super successful.
We also have customers who have
multi-10 or 40 gig bonded lines
into us, so there's a variety
of scaling opportunities.
This Google Cloud
Interconnect slide--
this was announced this
week, and so pretty
excited about the fact that
we have a private connection
into our switch at
a colo facility.
And if you end up with
through a third party,
this is what that diagram
looks like in terms
of being able to have a
service provider providing
the feed for you, and
then a connection to you.
So the opportunity to connect
directly with us is available,
and we're keen for
customers to be able to have
that functionality.
One thing I encourage
people to do if they're
on the nerdy side, as I am--
Jupiter Fabric.
So we name our different
network fabrics
after celestial
objects, it's true.
So Jupiter is the name
of the network fabric
that this is like a--
basically, a 2012
circa research paper.
There's a blog post
that's really accessible,
and then there's this
multi-page paper.
This image comes from the blog
post and is also in the paper
itself.
What I think is
really cool about it
is there's some top
researchers that
diagram and explain how the
software defined networking
works at Google.
There's pictures of the
racks within the data center,
there's diagrams explaining
how Interconnects work,
how top of rack switches work.
The fact that as opposed
to having maybe 10 gig
econnections you
may have on prem,
we're running 40
gig interconnects
between our various
hosts and such.
So the opportunity
to have control
over the complete software stack
as well as the hardware side
enables us to have really
flexible quality of service,
and be able to run
at really high rates.
And that difference in network
is a huge differentiator
for us.
And I encourage anyone to
Google that, the paper will just
pop up.
Jupiter fabric is
a great keyword.
So in terms of how do you store
the data for render jobs, yeah,
there's all sorts of
different offerings at Google.
It's all object
and block for us,
and so we'll just dig into
that a little bit more.
On the object side, we
have Google Cloud Storage.
I'll talk about
the different tiers
of that, and the availability
of them and how they work
and durability and such.
But on the block side,
that's really more analogous
to what you're used to
dealing with on prem.
So everybody is using an NFS
posits compliant file system
on prem, that's just
what the tools need.
And in that context, we
offer persistent disk,
both HDD for hard
drive variant, which
is our standard persistent
disk, and we also
offer SSD, persistent disk.
Now, these PD offerings are
both network attached storage,
and they are incredibly fast.
What's cool about them is
they can scale as well,
so expect these numbers
to go up over time.
The other cool thing
that I love is local SSD,
and we'll go into
some use cases later,
but that is super high speed
attached to the VM physically.
It's 700,000 IOPS, basically
the speed of DDR ram, DR2
in terms of use
capabilities, and it's
less expensive than
buying RAM in the machine.
So you may want
to have an option
to control the size of your VM
and augment it with local SSD.
We can talk about those
strategies in a bit.
In terms of the block store
for Google Cloud Storage,
multi-regional--
fantastic offering
in the fact that it
lets you store data
in two locations that
are more than 150 miles apart.
So if you're
serving content, you
want to have disaster
recovery, you
want to guarantee that you have
the data in multiple locations
that are physically far
apart and disparate,
then multi-regional
is your friend.
For most VFX workloads
for storing the data,
we recommend regional.
That guarantees the
data's in the region
you're doing the compute on it.
It's inexpensive,
highly available.
We also have near line and cold
line as longer term storage
options.
So the neat part
with all this is
that it all runs in
the same subsystem,
and the same API for access.
You have the ability
to get all the data
available to you on a per object
basis within milliseconds.
There's no difference in the SLA
for access time between this.
You can see the pricing, this
is all available on the web
as well.
The-- I guess the kind
of relevant use bits
are regional and
multi-regional, you're
just paying for what
use as you use it.
Near line has a 30 day,
and cold line has a 60--
sorry, 90, I should say.
The use case that we see is
people aging the data off.
So you set it on
regional and use it,
and you can, if you choose, set
an auto timer that will move it
to the longer term tiers,
or you can do so yourself,
as I mentioned, on
a project basis.
With near line, that is--
that's data we tend to put for--
kind of about a year.
If you're going to
access it within a year,
near line makes the
best economic sense.
If you're going to leave
it parked for more than a
year and it's kind of
your LTO tape replacement
as a long term
storage option, we
encourage people to
put it on a cold line,
and that gives you
the option of being
able to park the data there
for a very long period of time.
I had a question in
my talk yesterday
about bit rot, what
do we do about that.
We have some
proprietary technology
that goes through and
ensures the data's fresh
and ensures the integrity of it.
So you can park your data on a
cold line with the confidence
that it's going to be
there years from now
when you go to read it.
So using them all together.
As I mentioned, the per object
storage class is really cool.
If you put 15
petabyes on and you're
working with 300 terabytes
that may be large,
and someone comes to
you and it's a VFX show,
and you're working on
a sequel, because there
are so many of those
these days, and you
need to go back and get the
geometry and texture files.
You're going to
rerig the character,
you're going to put the
different muscle set up on it
and such, but you want
the texture files.
You want the MARI
archive, you want
to get the geometry
that was used.
You can go through and just
pull those objects out,
and you can get access to
them incredibly quickly.
If it's something you're going
to be rereading multiple times,
move it to regional.
If you're just going to read
it once and restore it locally,
then just grab it
on a cold line.
So in terms of NFS
file system options,
there's a couple of
different options.
We have a roll your own single
node filer, which we think
is pretty great.
It's inexpensive, and the
fact that it's open source,
so it's essentially
free, but you're
paying for the VM
and the storage
is attached to it and the
network that it runs on.
But there's no additional
cost beyond that.
It is highly performant
because of our network,
and the local SSD is
[INAUDIBLE] cache,
and PDS is [INAUDIBLE] it.
So we find that we can
typically serve line rate
to a significant
number of machines.
You can also build out
multiple single load filers.
An example would be, you have
a kangaroo and a robot fight
sequence, and you want to
put the kangaroo on one
and the robot on the other.
So you put the alembic
data on those two.
You can put the
textures across those.
You can put a right
node elsewhere,
or you can split alembic caches
on one and textures on another.
If you have six different
characters in some superhero
film, you can split them
out across multiples,
and that's a fairly
common strategy.
That's fine if you want
to manage your nodes
and if that's how you're
architectured on prem.
There's also Gluster, which
is available as a managed
open source solution.
By managed, I should
say supported,
so a supported or a open
source self-supported solution.
Both of those are
cloud file systems,
and the fact that you have to
synchronize the data to get
there, we'll talk about
that an asset management
a couple of minutes.
In terms of caching
file systems,
though, we have a vFXT
and also Pixcache.
The cool part with those
is they're a cloud file
system that are NFS
pauses compliant,
but they also have a read
through cache functionality.
So you export your on premises,
high performance file system
to the cloud, and then
as your render nodes
read additional data, they hit
the cloud file system first.
If it's not there, they go
back on prem, grab it, and then
pull it up, and then
you're able to read it
multiple times in the cloud.
So this is a fantastic
diagram made by Adrian Graham,
a Solutions Architect in LA.
He put this together, and
it explains pretty much how
you'd architect for the cloud.
This is something he
and I collaborated on.
In terms of-- maybe
you have license server
on prem and cloud
based license server.
There's a high speed
accelerated UDP transfer.
We can talk a little bit about
how to get things to the cloud.
The neat thing
about this, though,
is if you remove
the license server
and leave everything else
up, pretty much as it
is, you can go through and
take the rendering VMs over
in the corner and
changes those to GPUs.
Put an oil and gas
workload on this,
and suddenly you have a
high performance compute
scenario for that workload.
You can either choose to
go with local SSDs attached
to the machines for
simulation workloads,
or you can have a large NFS
file system in the cloud,
and your choice of
readthrough cache
is just dependent on
how your pipeline works.
I'll wait until evereyone
gets their photograph.
This will be available
on YouTube shortly, so,
excited about that.
But again, for me, the
most exciting thing
is the fact that any of the
different high performance
compute workloads I
mentioned earlier run
with this same architecture.
We have Genomics and
financial services all running
on this similar architecture
with really solid success.
Now, once you're
committed to us,
getting the data into the cloud,
that's the important part.
So we offer gsutil,
which is a command line
tool you have on
your local machine
that you can use to push
data to and from the cloud.
But simpler technologies--
or, actually,
alternate technologies,
such as rsync or Parsync,
with commercial
offerings as well,
with partners for
Aspera and Signiant,
those are for the
capability of providing
significant threaded
upload capabilities.
I'm sure everybody in this
room is making pictures,
and you guys are all
familiar with the technology.
The important thing here
is that Google is open.
If you want to run
your open source,
if you want to grab Tsunami
and compile it and put it
up and use that as your
transport protocol,
we're cool with that.
Our transfer mechanism,
I should say.
If you want a commercial managed
service, that's fine too.
In terms of asset management,
getting the data to the cloud,
that's--
it's a good problem to have.
The easy model is, OK,
we've done this stereo film,
we finaled the left eye, now
we want to take all the data,
we know everything that we need,
push it all up to the cloud,
and then spin the VMs up
and render the second eye.
We've had a couple
of customers do that.
That's not a common workload,
it's really easy in the fact
that, again, you
know everything you
need from a dependency
standpoint in advance,
you put it up, you
make the pictures.
More realistically, as a
commercial workflow or film
workflow, where you're
updating assets on the fly.
You've got your lighter
making changes in Kitana,
they're pushing the button,
textures may have changed.
You're in a scenario where
there's always something that's
changed before the
render goes up,
you need to make
sure it's there.
So these are a couple
of different strategies
to be able to get the data up.
The simplest thing we do
from a pipeline standpoint
is encourage people to
just put a simple rsync
in in their publishing step.
So when they publish and
commit and version up
within their pipeline, and then
let the next downstream user
know, or inform Shotgun,
or however you've
chosen to architect
it, a simpler rsync
will push that data
up to the cloud.
If you have a
caching file system,
you can have a micro node
sitting on the back side that
will read that data
through the cache,
and it will be warm
at least to be there.
One thing I should
point out on this slide,
we have one customer who I
think does a very clever thing.
After the render's
complete, they
create an H264 render of that.
And they do that at a
fairly low resolution.
They don't care about color
accuracy, what they want
is a really low bit rate, but--
I should clarify.
A reduced bit rate,
but sufficient quality
to make sure the
render worked properly.
Did the textures fall off, are
the lights in the right place,
does the render look
the way it should, then
they bring down their
2 or 4K, or however
large it's going
to be, giant EXR
files with 50 AOVs and such.
So that's a way to
manage your egress costs,
to ensure that you're not
just pulling 100% of the data
that you've written.
That's one thing we
discourage, in the fact
that if you pull every
temp file, every log file,
every simulation cache
down, your egress costs will
be higher than they need to be.
You can leave all that
data sitting in the cloud,
and it's going appear and
grab the bits you want
and pull them back out.
If you also leave
the data in the cloud
when you want to run
compositing passes later,
that's a really nice idea,
because you've already
got it there.
So as far as scheduling
jobs, we work
with a number of
commercial queuing options,
and bringing your own is
absolutely acceptable.
So in terms of block storage
for rendering, persistent disk,
most customers are using
PD SSD in terms of backing
their filers with that.
As an example, the Avere
will run on PD SSD,
but it will also
run on local SSD,
and there's a
significant performance
enhancement when you do that.
If you run the
Avere on local SSD,
you get roughly a 2x enhancement
across the board in terms
of sequential reads,
writes, and random writes,
but you get a 4 and a half time
improvement on random reads.
And for VFX effects
workloads, it's pretty much
a random read situation.
So it's super fast
with local SSD.
In terms of virtual
machines-- so because we
don't have an entirely
containerized pipeline running
on Kubernetes at this
time, for the most part
we're using standard VMs
for important workloads,
such as file systems,
gateways, and such,
and we're using printable
VMs for render nodes.
Now preemtiple VMs are
significantly discounted.
They're 80% off,
it's a penny a core.
So a 32 core machine is
32 cents US per hour.
So it's-- I made the
joke it's $3, $4.
In that context, you're
in a scenario where
you can run machines that
are incredibly inexpensive,
and at the same time you can
run a whole bunch of them.
And you can turn them on and
off on a per frame basis,
and we'll talk a
little more about that.
You'll notice as well that
it's the same subsystem you're
running on.
There's no difference.
The VM is identical,
it's just how we bill it
and how we support it.
We don't offer live migration
on the parental machines.
If we need to take some
of them back, we will.
It's excess capacity
that we sell.
So for workloads that are
important and critical
to the infrastructure, that
would be gateways, a license
server, file
systems, we encourage
you to be able to keep
those on a standard VM,
and we will migrate those
within our data center
if we have a service requirement
for the rack that they're on.
We'll move them somewhere
else while they're running.
I think it's really cool to
see a single load filer running
at full load, and then
have it migrate real time
and switch over in an
instantaneous period--
instantaneous, yeah, I know.
It's super fast, and it's
a really cool technology
that only we have.
The preemptible VMs
we encourage customers
to run with checkpoints,
snapshots, and such.
So that way you can run an 8,
a 12, a really long render,
and be in a scenario where
if the machine goes away,
you can spin the
machine up and you
get a 30 second warning
on a preemptible VM
that it's going away.
So you can chase
the log on that.
You can use our cloud logging
to inform your queuing
system that node is going away.
When that happens,
you can immediately
spin up another machine.
You know, I haven't
personally seen any situations
where we stock out.
We don't guarantee availability,
obviously, however,
I personally haven't
seen a scenario
where a customer has
completely stocked out
a zone in such a way
that they can't fire up
additional machines.
So in that situation,
that means there's
a machine on that
rack over there,
and you can spin that one up.
That machine comes up
in about 35 seconds,
so you can start loading the
scene as that other one is
still writing its
checkpoint, if you can
get that last checkpoint off.
So in terms of
different models when
you're looking at VFX
rendering, the most common one
we run into people who
haven't done any rendering
in the cloud yet is a
rental model where they're
used to going to Bob and Sarah's
rental service and a truck
rolls in and a couple racks
come often and they rack them up
and they plug them in and
they bin pack the jobs.
That means they're buying 300
machines for four days or three
weeks.
And they wait a couple of
days to get the machines.
And they have them for a period
of time and back they go.
Another model beyond that
is a collocation model.
So you don't have
enough space on-prem.
Perhaps you're in London.
Cooling is an issue.
Real estate is challenging.
You want artists
there as opposed
to machines in the closet.
So you rent a colo
space somewhere else,
run some fiber to it.
That's great.
However, the scale is
fixed in that scenario.
You've just sort of moved
the problem somewhere else
in that regard.
The dynamic model is the
one that I'm personally
most excited about
and the fact that you
take advantage of our per
minute billing capability.
And you can scale kind of
as much as you need to.
If you come to us and
say, we need 50,000 cores,
we don't have just unlimited
cores sitting around
all the time.
But if you let us know
what it is you need,
we'll give you a quota that
we can give you access to
at any given time.
But if you need something
really massive--
you're rendering a
ride film and it's
a high frame rate or it's
crazy large and it's stereo,
and so now you're
dealing with 6K images
and there's two of them and
you're doing 60 FPS and such,
if you need to render that
at final production quality,
you know in the
schedule from production
when that's going to occur,
you'll let us know in advance
and we can get you
120,000 cores or more.
It really just comes
down to working with us
from a scheduling standpoint,
because Google Cloud
Platform running on
the same infrastructure
as the rest of Google
is in a scenario where
we can work with the
scheduling and capaciting teams
internally and turn
up and make available
a large block of machines for
you across a couple zones.
But at the same time, that's
a huge amount of scale.
So in terms of workloads, kind
of excited about the fact that
beyond rendering,
and although this
is a rendering-centric talk,
the same infrastructure that you
put in place architecturally
to be able to run and make
pictures on the cloud enable
you to also do high performance
geometry caching for really
heavy scenes in Houdini
for instance or in Bifrost
with Maya, simulation, FLIP,
fluid solvers, destruction,
finite element,
deep compositing in Nuke, all
of that's available to you.
And we're also able to handle
everything from camera ingest
from Camera Raw, debayering,
editorial, all the way
through to archive after you've
done final content delivery.
So one of the workloads that
I spent a bunch of time tuning
in production was simulation.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about some fluid simulation
and point out some of the
differences between rendering
and how to get around some
of the common perceptions
of, how do we do fluid
sim in the cloud?
That seems really complicated.
There's a silly amount
of compute and RAM
required in order to be
able to do simulations.
The files they
write are massive.
20 to 40 gigs per
frame is what I
was writing when I was on-prem
at Animal Logic at one point
for "Sucker Punch."
I found that almost a
third of my simulation time
was write speeds
across the network.
And we had a great network there
and a new high speed filer.
But just they were large files.
They took time to write.
And the solver that
I was using initially
wouldn't initiate
the second frame.
So we had to make some
tweaks and changes.
But the opportunity to be
able to write to local SSD
is nearly instantaneous.
It's super fast with
the high speed storage.
So the wedging term is something
that a simulation artist
has to do.
It's an old film term moved
forward into digital land.
But the idea would
be that you want
to make a fluid
simulation, in this case.
You have to figure
out what the value is.
Everybody who's run
simulations in this room
knows that it's a
nonlinear situation
in terms of the solver.
In the solver you
can't just say,
oh, I want to make
the force double,
so I'm just going
to double the force.
It doesn't always work that way.
You need time on the box
in terms of number of hours
of working with the simulator.
So if I would start a
shot on a Monday morning,
it might be Wednesday before
I have run enough simulation
passes to figure out what is the
vorticity going to look like,
what is the impulse
force look like.
This is a simple
resolution change.
And you can see the
number of voxel delta
as well as the change in
the look of the simulation.
You can notice that the curling
is completely different.
It's not just a higher
resolution version of it.
The solver actually looks
a little bit different.
So it's essential for
the simulation artist
to be able to have
an opportunity
to wedge quickly and be
able to get responses back.
Adrian Graham gave this a go.
And this is some code
that he put together,
both a MEL and a Python
version of it for wedging.
And he used Maya Bifrost.
I've also built this in Houdini.
It's extensible in your
own solver as well.
This is how you actually run
the individual simulations.
The code samples will
be visible on YouTube.
So you'll be able to reproduce
chunks of this if you wish.
So in terms of should be
able to deploy the wedges,
this opportunity is really cool.
I like the idea of a simulation
artists being able to say,
I want to run this workload.
And I want to spin up
eight 64 core machines
with 250 gigs of RAM.
You can go with custom shapes.
So if your solver flattens
out at 48 cores, no problem.
28 cores, whatever
the optimum number
is in terms of RAM
and CPU, you only
pay for what you use
on a permanent basis.
So in this context you're going
to do the base simulation.
And then you're going to have to
mesh that so you have a render
object.
And then on top of
that, you're going
to do additional passes
based on that surface
object you've made.
And then you end up
with the test render.
The key though in
this scenario is
to keep all the
data on the cloud.
You write the really
expensive base simulation out.
Leave it there.
The high resolution
mesh you generate,
you can leave it there as well.
And when you do the
render, you don't
care about color accuracy
for a simulation.
You're just looking for motion.
So you're going to have a
shot camera, and if you wish,
a witness camera.
So you can have those
two JPEGs generated.
You can pull those down, display
them on a simple HTML page
if you want, and you can see
all eight simulations running.
And you can choose which
ones you want to kill.
So in terms of the architecture
of how do you make that work,
this is a nice
little description
of just saying, we have
some sim VMs in the cloud,
a license server
to make them work.
You can point back on-prem, and
then you have some local disk.
It's really easy.
You put the files in the
cloud on a local SSD.
You run the simulations.
When you're done,
you shut it off.
And as the machines are
running in this example,
you can turn off three or
four of them right away.
And you can turn
off additional ones.
We can get like one,
three, and seven,
you think those are
going to be a good one,
you let those continue
to run over lunch
and come back and check them.
And then you have some idea
of what kind of numbers
are going to work for
you to get that look.
If you want to do a full
workstation build out,
this is what that
architecture looks like.
And the cool part
with this is you'll
notice that we have both
local workstations and sim
VMs working here.
So you can be in
a scenario where
you're running both hybrid
and in the cloud for this.
Something with our GPU offering
is we offer both compute GPUs.
So if you want to use a renderer
like Octane, for instance,
and you want to be
able to render on GPU
or you wrote your own custom
GPU fire solver, for instance,
we have a significant
number of compute GPUs that
are available and becoming
available in all of our data
centers around the world.
We also have display
GPUs becoming
available in the
next little bit.
And the cool part
with that is you
can use something like Teradici
for a PC over IP solution
and you can have a
remote desktop session.
And there are a number of
well-known software providers
that we're working with who
are in a position of being
able to offer their software
through this service.
So the zero client
is really nice.
You get this tiny little box.
It'll run multiple 2K monitors.
The nice thing is if you
need to hire 30 artists,
you can go out
and get 30 artists
and you can give them monitors,
mice, keyboards, Wacom tablets,
and a thin client--
done.
And they're now able
to work in the cloud.
In a shorter term
scenario, you can
have artists who can't
get that shot finished.
They're in a difficult place.
Their rig is too heavy.
The muscle sim is
just taking too long.
You can give them a machine
that has twice as much RAM
or double the cores or
some combination of that.
And that's really
compelling if you've
be able to get difficult
shots through the pipeline.
So a sim factory in the cloud--
we have a whole bunch
of compute and storage.
And now we have display
and compute GPUs.
So we're really
trying to round out
the complete offering
of what's required
to be able to have a
completely virtualized pipeline
in the cloud.
The last thing that I'm
going to talk about here
is the idea of a
production safety valve.
It's important, I think,
to be able to engage
with us a little earlier.
I do get calls from people
and emails saying, hey,
we're delivering this
thing on Tuesday.
It's Thursday at
2:00 in the morning.
And there are some
problems and they
need to be able to
get something out.
We can help in that
scenario, it's true.
But it's quite a
bit easier if you
engage in a proof of
concept a little earlier.
And then we're in
a scenario where
you're set up and able
to run on the cloud.
You don't have to use it.
You just have the capability.
And that way if production
comes to you and says,
hey, the director
changed their mind--
that happens-- and we need
to be able to live with this,
or another facility,
schedule doesn't work out,
we can take on an
extra two sequences,
but we don't have the
render power for it,
you can say no problem.
We can render this on Google.
And we're already
set up to do so.
And with that, I'd like to
bring Hannes up on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you sir.
HANNES RICKLEFS: There we go.
JEFF KEMBER: For you.
HANNES RICKLEFS:
Brain, thank you.
And just leave my water here.
Cool.
Well, hi everybody.
I'm really super
excited to be here.
What I'm going to do over
the next kind of 30 minutes
is to take you on a bit
of a journey for how
Google Cloud help MPC
kind of bring the "Jungle
Book" to life, showing
some of the key challenges
that we faced, give
you an overview
of the technical design
that we implemented,
and then also give you
kind of an outlook, where
we kind of see the cloud
going for us in the future.
First, a little bit about MPC.
So we craft visual experiences
for both feature film
VFX and advertising, also
including virtual reality
and digital installations.
We've been around
for over 25 years.
This is some of the past movies
that we've been working on.
Here's an overview of all the
projects that we did in 2016.
Well, actually not all of them.
We completed a total of 15
projects on the film side.
And on the advertising
side, it was
2,019, which is a
great number if you
have to put on the same
slide with 2016 to remember.
So although we delivered
15 movies in 2016,
we tend to work on
roughly 20 projects
at any given point in time.
So these ones are about
to deliver this year.
But a lot of these were
already in the making in 2016
and going to be close to screen
to you at some point this year.
MPC is roughly 2 and 1/2
thousand people worldwide,
the majority being split between
Vancouver, Montreal, London,
and Bangalore.
All of our productions are
run across at least two
of those sites.
That's predominately due to
make leverage specialisms that
are only available
in some of our sites.
So really close collaboration
and data transfers
between all of these sites
is hugely important for us
to deliver our productions.
So talking about
our productions,
in order for us to create
these visual effects,
we constantly need
to kind of plan
how many people,
how much compute,
and how much storage we require.
To do that, we look
at each of these shots
that we can kind of see
and we kind of break them
down for days that
we think we're
going to require in each of the
departments that are required
to make these shots.
So this gives us the
kind of like total amount
of mandates that we will
need for the project.
And from that we derive
schedules, which we then
use to see kind of that's the
people, that's the storage
and compute we require.
I'd kind of like to take
you through that process
in a bit of detail,
because it's actually quite
important for how we plan.
And then you can
kind of see really
how the cloud allows
us to change that.
Due to the nature of the
movies that we work on,
we tend to see these
kind of massive peaks
throughout the year
in predominantly kind
of late spring and
late autumn, which
is due to the summer and
winter blockbuster releases
that we're working on.
So as I mentioned, we
do roughly 20 projects.
What I'm going to do just
for simplicity's sake
is use an example
of kind of three
somewhat fictitious projects.
But the kind of scale that
I mention kind of literally
applies to all of
them that we work on.
So here is kind of the
result of us breaking down
all of the work that's
going to be required
and then kind of figuring
out how many people we need.
And this is really
the starting point.
From this, we then go and
have our internal models
that we then use to predict
the amount of compute
and the amount of
storage that we require.
What is kind of interesting,
that depending of the project--
so depending if it's a
character heavy shot, if it's
an effects heaving
shot, environment
heavy shot, these profiles
kind of change quite a lot.
So you can see this kind
of on the storage side.
The big challenge is
that all of these things
peak at the same time throughout
the production cycle literally.
So just imagine 15 more of
these kind of stacking up.
To give you an idea of
scale, when we talk people,
that's roughly a couple
of hundreds per project.
On the compute side, we're
talking millions of hours
to compute.
And on the storage
side, our projects
tend to be in around the
petabyte when they kind
of reach that peak capacity.
So that means that we
need to manage, plan,
and provision for these peaks.
We also need to build all of
our infrastructure to constantly
kind of be able to scale up
and down for us to deliver
our productions
without any impact.
The other thing is when
we look at the trends--
now this is kind of
like a 12 month schedule
right here-- we see these
shrinking quite significantly.
The thing that isn't shrinking
is the complexity of the shot
work that's required.
So these peaks are just going
to go and increase and increase
and increase.
Just an idea of scale--
for the "Jungle Book," we
had 800 people working on it.
In total it was 35
million wall clock hours
to compute the movie.
And at peak, the
"Jungle Book" required
2 petabytes of storage.
So let me give you a bit
of background details
of what the scale and
kind of complexity
that we faced on
the "Jungle Book."
In 2016, Disney awarded us
with the majority of the work
on the "Jungle Book."
We were tasked with creating
1,200 shots with over hundreds
of characters that we needed
to build, 60 environments,
over 2,000 environment assets.
That resulted in roughly
12 square miles of jungle,
which according to
Google is a quarter
of the size of San Francisco.
So you can kind of get the
perspective of how much we
actually had to build.
This watering shot that
you can see right here
had a total of kind of like
200 characters within it.
And it was also the
first shot to move up
to completely to
new software stack.
Now our software stack uses
a large amount of third party
software, but then a
huge amount of custom
tooling that we have to build.
And this was really
important because we
needed to hit the creative
and artistic vision that Jon
Favreau had set out, who was
the director on this movie.
It's been an absolutely
amazing experience for us,
really satisfying due to
just the recognition we've
received through the industry.
Because it was a
couple of weeks ago,
I think, that we finally
won the Oscar for the movie.
So it's been amazing.
But rather than talking, I
think lights and the audio
please, because
this is a breakdown
of some of the FX work that
was required for the movie.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
HANNES RICKLEFS:
So as you can see,
quite a lot of fluid
stimulation, as Jeff was--
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Right.
So as I just mentioned
before the clip,
there was quite a lot
of new technologies
that was required for
us to deliver the movie.
One of those particular pieces
of third party technology
was a new version of Renderman,
which has really moved away
from its more traditional
rays-based pipeline
to a completely
native path tracer.
We have a really great
relationship with Pixar.
And some of the
initial tests that we
did with this new
version gave us
the absolute great confidence
that the photo realistic kind
of visuals that were
required to deliver
would be possible
with this new version.
The thing is, we
fine tune kind of
like all of our compute tasks
specifically for the task.
So we look at what's
the optimum in terms
of CPU versus RAM
versus storage per task.
In addition, we kind of had to
revamp our internal rendering
software stack to make
use of this new version.
So it's actually quite
a significant risk
for a production
to say, well, we're
going to change our renderer.
To give you an idea
of that scale, when
I mentioned that the "Jungle
Book" took 35 million render
hours to finish--
so that includes everything,
like simulations and all that--
80% of that is
Renderman related hours.
So it was kind of a significant
risk for us to do it.
But I'm really glad we did.
The other thing is,
there was a huge amount
of internal development
that we needed to do,
ranging for how do we
model the environments,
how do we simulate
all the jungle,
how do we improve our
character animation, and also
various workflow improvements.
So one of the ones
that I want to pick on
is, we really needed to move
up our quality for our QC
and kind of just approval
renderers, which traditionally
would be more of these kind
of like puppets cut up,
and tend to use kind of like
OpenGL GPU-based visuals.
So what we did is
we actually said no,
we're going to use
Renderman for that
as well, which meant
that we were going
to go from something
like this to something
like this as part
of the QC step.
It was really important for
our animation department
to see the impact of fur for of
that kind of little subtleties
in relation to the performance.
So this was really important for
us to get right for this movie.
Now what that meant is that
due to the volume of "Jungle
Book," due to all of this new
technology, our plans, when
I showed you those
graphs for compute,
they reached new heights.
So in essence we needed to
do and get more compute.
Now our existing approach, like
Jeff mentioned, we would go out
and we would go
and purchase and we
could look at our
data center and get
all of that stuff in there
and get ready and then use it.
Or we would go out and lease it.
But that, for the time
frame that we needed,
was going to be very cost
ineffective, and also kind
of challenging to get in
time for when it was needed.
Now we had already had
multiple conversations
with Google to see how can we
use the cloud to actually give
us a third option.
And this time, like
all parties, said,
we're going to go to and do it.
So what did we set out?
We wanted to add 10,000 cores
for a duration of two months.
However-- and this is
really important-- it
was crucial to provide
this additional compute
with an official
approval from our client.
So that meant we
needed it to meet
there's and our internal
security standards
for cloud-based compute.
All of our sites are
regularly audited
literally at multiple
times throughout the year
on our internal architecture
and our technical implementation
to ensure that they're aligned
with the security practices
that are part of the industry.
To do that, MPC
and Technicolor--
so Technicolor is
MPC's parent company--
we partnered with ISE--
they're the Independent
Security Evaluators--
to provide a security
assessment of our kind
of remote compute
platform, and then
before submitting that proposal
to Disney for approval.
This was an ongoing process
throughout the whole project
because any alterations,
any new appliances
that we wanted to introduce
needed to be re-evaluated
and then resubmitted
to approval.
So here is the kind of technical
design that we ended up with.
MPC's existing infrastructure
is built around centralized NFS
filers for both software
and production content.
Both of these receive
multiple updates per day
in terms of, on
the software side,
new tools, new configurations.
So they're in constant kind
of influx and being worked on.
All of MPC's sites are connected
via Technicolor's production
WAN.
But all of these kind of
film production zones,
which is one of the big
of security requirements,
do not have any external
connectivity-- so no access
to the internet from them.
There are some shared services
zones that you've got here
that do have external
connectivity.
But these are tightly controlled
with application and kind
of like network [INAUDIBLE].
So the initial design that
we kind of put forward
is to use VPN tunnels to provide
burst capacity into Google's
cloud using VPN tunnels.
The big thing was
is there was going
to be no production
content in the cloud,
only for temporary logs and some
scratch base that was required
for some of our applications.
To provide these VPN end
points, MPC worked with Sohonet.
So they have a product
called FastLane
which enabled us to
get the kind of VPN
connectivity that we
required given the network
throughput requirements
that we had.
So since this
initial setup, we've
actually started to
use the Google managed
VPN on the GCP side.
But we're still on
the FastLane product
on the Technicolor side.
With this initial design,
we knew from the beginning
that we had to deal with
latencies, because we
weren't going to rearchitect
any of our internals.
So we chose Europe-West to just
reduce the amount of latency
that we had from
our London site.
However, the kind of nine
milliseconds that we measured
was too much for
some of our tools
that really were used
to really quick access
to our application's filers.
Various different interesting
timeouts were encountered.
In addition, when we increased
to more and more calls,
they just became more
and more apparent.
So to deal with this--
it was kind of on one of
the slides from Jeff--
what we initially did is
we put out our application
file out into the cloud.
Our preference would
have been to just use
the Avere virtual
appliance that existed.
Unfortunately, this didn't
quite work out of the box.
Because of our
security restrictions,
what the Avere needs to
do is to actually speak
to the Google APIs, which
wasn't possible in the setup
that we had.
Now we already use
Avere internally.
We forefront all of our
application and content filers
with the Avere.
So we have a great
connection with them.
They came in and they
actually helped build us
a custom virtual
appliance that was then
able to perform within
our system architecture.
Now along with
the Avere, we also
had kind of internal
tooling that
needed to require to
talk to the Google API
because, hey, we need to
provision machines, right?
We want new PVMs.
We want new standard instances.
So we needed to
figure out a way for,
how do we make this kind
of communication happen?
And the proposal
that we put forward
was to use kind of like
a tiered proxy, which
kind of enabled
bootstrapping and any
of the kind of APIs requirements
to get GCP resources
and for the Avere.
Now all of this was of course
resubmitted to ISE, and then
also to Disney for approval.
So this is kind of the final
design that we put in place.
So on the GCP side,
we had render nodes.
So these were dedicated
to run the render task.
They were a mixture of PVM
and standard instances running
in MPC custom center six image.
We had file servers, again,
purely for kind of locks
and any temporary
scratch that was required
by some of our application,
also running a custom MPC center
six image.
Then the VPN end points, they
were worked on by Sohonet
to provide us the network
performance through our VPN
setups, and then the
Avere virtual appliance,
which was the custom
MPC Avere builds
to really help on optimizing the
performance that we required.
And really most
importantly, that no content
was ever stored at
rest in the cloud.
We can assume that
behind the scenes
we had host and key
management all in place.
And there were strong
role-based authorization
to ensure strict access for
any kind of admin and support
throughout this platform.
Now just-- I like my graphs.
So here is to show you kind of
the importance of the Avere.
So this was a graph of
one of the render nodes
without the Avere.
And if you kind of pay
attention to the left hand side
if I change the scale, so once
the Avere was put in place,
we moved from literally 50 reads
per second up to 2,000 reads
in a second.
Now this is really
important because when
you look at the
performance of a renderer,
they like to read a lot of data.
That's due to the
amount of texture,
to the amount of geometry, and
just various different data
types.
So this was really important
for us to be put in place.
The other thing that
was important was--
or literally-- as a
consequence, we obviously
had huge amount of
network traffic drop,
with the red line
kind of marking
when we had the Avere in place.
So at this point in time,
we're really happy, right?
We solved the security.
We got all of the throughput
that we needed to do.
So it was now questions
like, how much can we
fire up the cloud?
And this is where I'm going
to hand over to the video
again to just show
you the choice of what
we could put up on the cloud.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HANNES RICKLEFS: And
there's audio again.
[END PLAYBACK]
HANNES RICKLEFS: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you again.
Now unfortunately,
our production budgets
are not quite as
infinite as the resources
that you can get into the cloud.
So what we had to do is
kind of a bit of work of,
how do we identify
what kind of jobs
makes the most sense
to send to the cloud,
whilst keeping within our
production constraints?
First off, we kind
of went into, well
what's the ideal criteria
to send task to the cloud?
For us, that was tasks
with limited I/O,
to just ensure we were not
going to-- because remember,
the production content
was always on our end.
So any kind of
download and any rights
would cost egress charges--
and generally to be
quite compute heavy.
So we just make sure we make
use of the great instances
that we had out there.
They should be
tolerant to preemption
so that we could make use of
the lower cost PVMs wherever
possible.
In general, that meant that
our lighting and rendering
tasks just fitted that profile
a lot better than comp and FX,
which tend to be extremely high
I/O, and also very intolerant
for preemption if you just kill
the simulation halfway through.
So our RenderMan tasks were the
ones that we targeted first.
The improvements
to our QC process
to move to RenderMan
in comparison
to kind of the OpenGL renders,
plus the volume of shots
that we had had thousands of
tasks in our internal backlog.
So luckily from the QC
kind of perspective,
you don't necessarily need
a full sequence of frames
to ensure that things
like lighting directions--
I mean, I can look at
this image and say yep,
the lighting direction is OK.
I don't need to see
everything else.
We can just move that along
and do a final render.
And also kind of from
animation perspective,
you were OK to just see
the performance even
if kind of frames were missing.
It was more important
to just have a reference
point to ensure, yes,
from a QC perspective,
we're actually able to
move these things along.
So these kind of QC renders
was a perfect target
we send to the PVMs.
Now our production moves through
a large number of departments
that are kind of shown here.
All of our work is kind of
split into two main areas.
We have what we
call the build areas
where we construct all
of our kind of characters
and environments.
And then we reuse those on all
the various different shots.
For the "Jungle Book," I
mean, every single department
was important.
But the kind of two
key ones was animation,
from just a
performance perspective
that we had to
deliver, and lighting
to ensure that we can deliver
the photo realistic visuals
that were required to meet
the vision of the director.
Now our ability to add
additional resources
for the animation QC,
and then from a lighting
QC and final render
standpoint, enabled production
to be really confident
that we are going to hit
the demands of the shows.
So on a daily basis,
kind of what happened
was that we looked
at our daily backlog
in terms of volume
and priorities.
If required, a budget was set.
And also priorities
were provided
to then ensure we knew
kind of like what we wanted
to get through in the night.
So we used Tractor,
one of the schedulers
that was mentioned by Jeff,
for our internal management
of our hosts and the submission
and processing of the tasks.
So there was kind of
like two main areas
that we needed to develop
our own tools for.
One was for the
automatic provisioning.
So this was to say given
the budget, how many PVMs
and how many standard
instances do we require?
And then on the other
side was kind of
like how do we
ensure that we can
get kind of the right tasks
sent over to the cloud?
What was important
here is in order
to make best use of
the Avere, we kind of
needed to ensure
that we can only
send kind of like the same
kind of scenes or shots
to the farms.
So make sure, that,
hey, lets just
make sure the water hole
shots all go to the cloud,
or lets make sure that only
the jungle sequence here
on the bottom goes.
So that way the cache
wouldn't constantly
kind of trash itself.
And that worked really well.
And then also to say
that Tractor in itself
really handled the
load quite well
of all of these new
additional machines
that we're going to
add on a nightly basis.
So we didn't need to do
any work to just handle
the increased load that
was on Tractor itself.
All right, just
leaves me to conclude.
First off, here's
some statistics
of how much we used the cloud.
At kind of peak,
we added in excess
of 14,000 cores per night.
Overall, they computed
360,000 hours.
That's roughly 41 years.
1.5 million tasks
were completed.
Internally, we think this
was a really great success
across our technology,
operations, and production
teams because everybody
came together.
You needed to control
the amount of money
that we were going
to spend, and we
needed to know that we
actually can get the throughput
and have all of the tech ready.
The agility and just
general availability
of the cloud resources enabled
literally millions of tasks
to be completed in
a very short time.
So if we look at kind of what
I call are the key benefits--
so the quickly added capacity,
this was really important.
When a production of
that scale is in demand,
you want to ensure that they
feel as confident that they can
that yes, we're going to be
able to deliver the movie.
This was really
important for us.
The agility, just in terms of
being able to say, hey, today
I want 70% PVMs and only
30% standard instances
was really important so we
can guide it on a daily basis.
The other thing
that we found, which
was really cool was that as
I mentioned in the beginning,
we kind of fine tune our
processes to say, all right,
what's the split
of CPU versus RAM
on these particular machines?
On the cloud, actually
getting a new machine profile
is really easy.
You just say, hey, I want
this kind of configuration
and be done.
If I would have to
do that internally,
it's actually quite
a lot of effort
to make sure that we can
reportion parts of our farm.
So this actually helped us
to do a lot of playground
testing The other part is, we
now have established security
processes and documentation
and everything
that we can now go and engage
with a lot of our other clients
to also ensure that we can use
the cloud for their projects.
Then controlled cost
and [INAUDIBLE],
again, our budgets
are quite constrained.
So knowing of what
we can compute,
what we're able to deliver, and
the associated costs with this
is really important.
And then finally, we've
now really established
some really close partnerships
across the various different
third party--
well, the cloud, Jeff
and all these guys,
which really helps us kind
of look into the future.
So let's look into the future.
We strongly believe
in the future
of the cloud for visual effects.
So we're now
working on a project
to literally take our
whole platform cloud
native to enable us to
process our visual effects.
Now our core platform
tooling that we already
have is built around concepts
or cloud-like concepts.
So we have a strong
microservices framework.
We have a well established
asset management platform.
And our software and kind of
build and configuration system
is all built around containers.
That we have all
of these things.
What's nice with
the cloud, I'm now
able actually run that
in an environment which
is kind of separated from
our existing infrastructure.
So I can iterate a
lot quicker, which
then helps me to build
out that new platform
and then being able to change
my internal stack a lot easier.
Also, if this stuff is of
interest to us, we are looking.
We are hiring.
So do we have a look at that
link and/or grab me afterwards.
Now here's kind of the
outlook where we see us
kind of moving in
terms of the cloud.
Rather than going through every
single one of those departments
one by one, what we
actually want to do
is just take the whole
lot and move to the cloud,
and then being able to
literally just pull down
the QC and kind of like final
renders to look at locally.
Now that would mean
we could use the cloud
to also manage our
storage constraints
and more importantly, deal
with the kind of like intersite
connectivity, because the
global nature of our productions
just is what we do.
So this just lets
me to thank Disney
for just allowing me to show
you not only the amazing visuals
but also the technical
artistry that was required
to bring the "Jungle
Book" to life,
my colleagues at
Technicolor, my team at MPC--
it's been an ongoing
dedication and passion
to just embrace this
new technology--
Sohonet and Avere for
really being behind us
for their availability
and their ongoing support,
and for the GCP team.
I mean, Thomas, [INAUDIBLE],
[INAUDIBLE], and Jeff,
these guys are amazing.
And just this ongoing
collaboration,
we're looking forward to
see what the future brings.
So with this, just want to
thank you all for listening.
And I guess--
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]